C'est quand même toute une
histoire, en Mauricie, des
des vaches qui se sont échappées
de leur enclos l'été dernier,
Amélie Dmamarais, bonsoir, vous
avez piqué notre curiosité. Le
trouauau, on parle d'un certain
nombre de vaches quand même, et
dans la nature depuis des mois
et c'est des cowboy de cinq
rescousse.
- Une histoire des citoyens d'un
scénario de film, ont vendu 29
vaches qui vivent dans le bois
et derrière moi depuis le mois
de mai. À ce moment-là, il y a
eu des vents violents qui ont
endommagé leur enclos, ils ont
prient la poudre d'escampette.
On voit des vaches que ce sont
d'autres qui appartiennent au
l l l l l l l l l l l l l l l y
a un ruisseau, une forêt assez
dense et donc un certainenenent,
les vaches se retrouvaient dans
la voie publique, la
municipalité a conetetetet le
MAPAQ, le mystère de la forme de
la SPCA, tout le monde relance
la balle. Un certain moment de
suggéré à la municipalité
d'abattre leeseseses, mais pas
question d'aller dans cette
directioa a a a décidé de faire
appel au festival western de
Saint été assez cowboy, car qui
sont venus sur place, qui ont
dededede récupérer les bêtes
pendant une journée complète
mais qui n'ont pas réussi à la
toute dernière minute, les sente
maire ainsi que le chef de cette
équipe de cowboy.
JEAN-YVES SAINT-ARNAUD,
maire de Saint-Sévère
- On ne pouvait pas intervenir
des terres des privés
des gens, des agriculteurs.rsrsé
à sortir, ces bête ont commencé
à sortir sur la route,
ils mettaient en danger à à à à.
SYLVAIN BOURGEOIS, dir. rodéos,
Festival western de St-Tite
- On est descendus, une gang
de chums, avec les chevaux et
les remorques, puis on a réussi
à regrouper le tr
une vingtaine de vaches.
Par contre, le mait t t t t pas
été battu encore, puis ils sont
arrivés dans un grand champ
de long par un demi-kilomètre l,
on les a réchappées.
- Ils les ont reperdus, les d de
champ parce que c'était tropl'l,
nous, on a les chèvres, vous
avez des vaches que c'estlllllÇe
pose plus, elles vont avoir
faim.a a a a a a a a a a a a a a
a causé des dizaines de milliers
de dollarseseseseseses les gens
étaicococococococontents. Hélas,
avec le temps froid, on pense
qu'on va capable de les attirer
avec de la nourriture, mais
ce sont des bêtes qui ont repris
des comportements sauvages. On
ererererererer justement un
producteur de lait.ucucucucucuce
- Elles étaient pour mettre bas
à ce stststststststement.
Elles ont commencé d'ailleurs
à mettre bas un peu partout.
Mais celles-là étaient...ququque
qu'on trait tous les jours.
Elles sont plus
à redevenir sauvages.
- Est peut-être plus heureuse,
en tout cas, mais là, c'est un
animaux. OK, mais un sujet
sérieux, tout à fait. Améli